des passe-droits quelle est la question
dépasse 3 3 des passe droits oui qu'on
demandait des people à michel cymes non
ce n'est pas ça la bonne réponse c'est
qu'a demandé bernard montiel au centre
de point soleil c'est bien ça la bonne
réponse que demande des célébrités au
médecin michel cymes pour se faire
vacciner sur l'histoire incroyable d'un
michel cymes qui a fait une confidence
surprenante auprès de pure people de
compost ainsi tous les people sont pures
[Rires]
quand on est une célébrité on se croit
parfois tout permis ce que nous apprend
le docteur michel cymes qui s'est fait
vacciner la semaine dernière en direct à
la télévision peut-être que les français
vont se dire celui de la feb a on peut
le faire aussi pic grâce à ses
privilèges en tant que médecin se trouve
plus ou moins harceler de demande plutôt
déplacé comme je suis un peu dans le
milieu de la télé j'ai été appelé par
des gens très très célèbre qui ne sont
pas dans les plus de 75 ans ou les plus
de 50 ans soignant qui m'ont dit tu
pourrais pas essayer de m'avoir
sous-entendu un vaccin et michel cymes
en parle publiquement c'est bien entendu
parce qu'ils refusent ces privilèges
non il n'y a pas de passe droit comme
quoi être connus nouveau parfois pas
toutes les portes
est ce que vous êtes surpris par les
révélations de michel sims moi je trouve
ça terrible secousse envoie un signal
terrible pour les gens que les stars et
des et des passe-droits grâce à terry
depuis le premier confinement de marc je
suis certaine célébrité sur les réseaux
sociaux et j'en vois qui se baladent ami
ami à los angeles et c est pour info une
petite info personne n'en parle ou c'est
que l'aviation d'affaires bockel jet
privé sont pas soumis aux autres cas au
début du colis n'ont pas été soumis aux
règles du colis de salaire vous pouviez
voyager n'importe où donc y'a plein de
stars qui faisait l'envié en tout cas
pour nos pauvres pendant qu'on était
confiné non mais c'est vrai mais ça
parle mais oui c'est chaud vous dire que
léo j'entends que ce soir vous dites que
des vérités à ses vrais ses nouvelles je
vous regarder jouer l'hymne
c'est dingue avec une telle coiffure on
peut dire des choses et ça ils font qu'à
l'intelligence c'est sous cette mi-août
moi ce qui me choque c'est qui qui le
dise je suis désolé c'est pourquoi alors
maintenant non là il a droit données
dont il n'a pas donné de nom mais non
c'est pas bien ça jette un discrédit et
après on va pas se mentir secret
professionnel la médecin on est d'accord
il a pas d'idée non on va arriver seul
principe après c'est quoi la prochaine
étape et il a rajouté que il avait
refusé évidemment qui a refusé mais je
n'osais pas bien et on va encore dire
quoique les people et serge son célèbre
c'est pas bien voilà c'est tout ce que
je dis je vous l'avais bien non pas bien
morgan a et ben moi je pense que je sais
pas si c'est oui même si c'est non mais
en tout cas vu le nombre de personnes
qui veulent se faire vacciner choc c'est
pas mal d'avoir que quelques cobayes qui
accepte de le faire oui les artistes qui
marche pas mais moi je veux bien me
faire vacciner c'est par l'accident
c'est vraiment faire vacciner à moi oui
l événement n'était pas dans le coup
vous avez keinon oui s'il ya pas ça mais
encore non moi c'est au mois de mars au
mois de mars
j'aurais 64 ans au mois d'avril oui donc
c'est moi je ce jeu peut demander mois
de mars
non c'est vrai bien sûr tout de suite
très bien mal je peux le faire
maintenant
pas très bien mon bernard basset bien on
l'a dit les choses vont très bientôt
cobit 80000 euros par mois